E aí
[Música]
bom então vamos lá a gente ouvi muito
falar sobre a força do amor que o amor é
capaz de mover barreiras e de fazer as
coisas mais inimagináveis possíveis eu
ouvi isso durante a minha vida inteira e
eu sou um cara curioso cara quando eu vi
isso para lá pela centésima vez eu
decidi pesquisar para ver se isso era
realmente verdadeiro né gente o amor
realmente tinha essa força toda que as
pessoas falavam que ele tem e quando eu
comecei a pesquisa eu encontrei muitas
histórias que eu achava que na verdade
não passavam de lendas e algumas delas
eram de fato verdade essa foi uma das
histórias que eu mais me assustei quando
eu vi essa mulher ali que você tá vendo
na foto chama Ângela cavalo aí ela tá
junto com o filho dela e com o marido
ela tava na cozinha arrumando algumas
coisas ali para levar a mãe dela no
mercado né quando ela ouviu o grito do
filho dela pedindo por ajuda de alguma
maneira ela chegou do lado de fora de
casa na garagem dela ela viu o carro
dela e fala em pala e quase esmagando o
filho e ela conseguiu levantar o carro
que pesa 1500 kg por alguns segundos ali
o suficiente pro filho dela sair debaixo
do carro é realmente de imaginável
porque se você imaginar essa mulher
naquela época ela tinha mais ou menos 65
kg e 1,75 levantou um carro de 1.500 kg
não é um carro daqueles que não como os
carros de hoje vivem são feitos
praticamente de plástico né mas um
daqueles carros realmente feito de metal
ali e a ciência ficou buscando o
inúmeras explicações para isso na época
até que conseguiram encontrar algumas
coisas realmente interessantes na sobre
por quê que isso é possível porque que o
ser humano consegue
executar essas proezas ali né Qualquer
da onde vem essa tal força do amor o que
eu descobri dessas pesquisas aqui foi
basicamente esse gráfico aqui que não é
nada convidativo né Deu para entender
porque que os médicos colocam Doutor na
porta depois de simplesmente concluiu
bacharelado ali é porque realmente não
vai dar para estudar mais quatro anos e
ter concluído o doutorado eu estou e
vamos combinar aqui se eu botar do outro
e você também a gente vira todo mundo
Doutora é porque o negócio é realmente
muito complicado então para você que
assim como eu é leigo não entendi nada
disso ele a gente tem o funcionamento da
unidade motora a unidade motora é o que
realmente faz com que as fibras
musculares elas sejam convocadas pelo
nosso corpo para exercer a força
necessária para executar algum movimento
né isso vem lado do cérebro mesmo
cérebro ele conversa ali com os tecidos
musculares por meio de sistema tá o
tecido muscular ele é formado por uma
célula muscular que é basicamente eu nem
sei para quê eu vou falar nisso mas é
basicamente formada essa célula é
formada por duas proteínas actina EA
miosina né E aí quando o Raqueli essa
fibra muscular a fibra muscular
exercício movimento a gente é a mesma
quantidade mais ou menos a mesma
quantidade de células musculares mesmo
se você for na academia todos os dias
esse número não se altera e fica mais ou
menos estável ele é o mesmo número ali
então essas fibras musculares elas que
executam um movimento então quando
aperta aqui o botão para passar o slide
lá o seu corpo sabe que quando e ele tem
a Que [ __ ] é de fibras musculares aqui
mais ou menos para executar esse
movimento só que quando você tem
esses limites Ok esses limites aqui que
são estabelecidos nesse movimento eles
estabelecidos não só pela vontade de que
você tem de executar o movimento com
mais ou menos força como também pelos
limites que seu cérebro definir para te
proteger né então no máximo que você
consegue ali Executar a de movimentos em
selecionar ou sem causar algum problema
é em torno de quarenta por cento essa
exige ali e quarenta por cento das suas
fibras musculares essas fibras elas não
conseguem ser recrutados além desse
limite porque seu corpo cria essa trava
então para te proteger e isso explica
ali por quê que nós situação de grande
risco por exemplo uma mãe consegue
levantar um carro ali porque esses
limites são rompidos né esse limite a
rompido naturalmente Então você
conseguiria e da mesma forma Se você
ficasse pendurado no penhasco por
exemplo você ia demorar muito tempo para
largar seu corpo e a simplesmente
destruir essas fibras por mim o que elas
funcionando ali até o máximo que ele
conseguisse já que não faria muito
sentido Ele simplesmente ter saltado
penhasco para manter as fibras
musculares se você ia morrer né então
ele ia ter ele é poupar os esforços sem
necessidade então na situação de risco
seu corpo definir aquela máxima né quem
tem limite e município e Deixa isso para
lá para te proteger E aí a gente acabou
criando essa máxima é de que o amor ele
é imbatível ele remove os limites do seu
corpo o amor transforma o amor da força
é o amor vence barreiras e o amor pode
destruir fibras musculares causando
lesões porque se você realmente quiser
salvar alguém que você ama você
conseguiria aí a fazer isso então se por
um lado é difícil ativar sem por cento
das suas fibras musculares ou um
percentual acima desses quarenta por
cento utilizando o amor porque teria que
ser uma pessoa que você ama muito né em
uma situação muito muito específica
Então mamãe normalmente ela vai
conseguir fazer isso uma relativa
facilidade de na na hora que ela vê um
filho dela em perigo mas uma pessoa
normal você no dia a dia você e a
recrutar todas as suas fibras musculares
ali utilizando esse tipo de coisa porque
você não tem essas emoções no dia a dia
né
aí você pode se lembrar de quando você
era criança eu não sei se você tem
irmãos mas eu tenho dois a facilidade do
que você consegue utilizar toda a sua
força Ele tá brigar com seu irmão muito
mais velho quando você tá com raiva ela
é muito maior né se você tá brigando
pelo controle da TV ali a força que dá
um soco no seu irmão que é pode ser
cinco anos mas é que você se realmente
consegue disputar de igual para igual
ali isso porque o outro combustível que
consegue também ativar as fibras
musculares mais facilidade de raiva a
gente além de utilizar é um percentual
maior das fibras musculares quando a
gente gosta muito de alguém que é
proteger essa essa pessoa quando está
com muita raiva também a gente sente o
corpo né é travando os músculos e
recrutando fibras musculares porque
normalmente a gente fica com raiva em
algumas situações onde a gente precisa
necessariamente utilizar a um maior
número de grupos musculares ali a quando
você tá realmente com alguém te batendo
a situação que Socorro precisa reagir de
alguma maneira ele acaba recrutando
essas fibras ele com mais facilidade foi
esse é o que a gente vai chamar aqui
nesse durante essa explicação de o poder
do ódio né então tem o poder ali do amor
que a gente tem também esse poder do
ódio e a gente tem inclusive um dos
nossos atletas olímpicos aí que tu e dou
a seguinte coisa depois que ele ganhou
ali né Depois de concorrer a natação ele
twittou os caras são grandes mas não é
ruim né o Bruno fratus aí depois de
ganhar Ele percebeu como o poder do
áudio funciona e mostra ele comemorando
aí falando sobre o como ele é ruim né só
que eu abro que a gente sabe que tá
fazendo eu sentido figurado da coisa EA
gente vai começar aqui sobre o que
realmente o ódio pode fazer por você né
De que maneira você conseguiria utilizar
e o ódio no seu dia a dia como que o
ódio pode ser utilizado por você nas
situações mais corriqueiras viu para
concentrar naquilo que você realmente
precisa
e esse estudo aqui da Jennifer Lopez é
uma pesquisadora da Universidade de
Harvard ele mostrou que ela acompanhou
ali depois dos atentados do dia do dia
onze de setembro né a mil pessoas e
essas mil pessoas que ela acompanhou ali
ela queria saber as emoções que eles
estavam sentindo depois Doze de Setembro
obviamente muitas pessoas se sentiram
vulneráveis e sentiram medo depois
daquele atentado final é o país delas
tinha sido invadido por outras pessoas e
ele dentro de casa né como se fosse
dentro do seu quintal a alguém vem lá e
faz mal para você de alguma maneira
algumas pessoas sentiram medo e algumas
outras pessoas sentirão raiva ela
percebeu que as pessoas que sentirão
raiva necessariamente as pessoas que
estavam ali não com medo mas com com
raiva mesmo essas pessoas se recuperaram
e produziram menos hormônios ele que
dificultavam a facilidade da ao
retornarem à vida normal delas ele Então
foi muito interessante os níveis de
pressão sanguínea e os hormônios ligados
ao estresse qual foram produzidas a
quantidade muito menor pelas pessoas que
sentirão raiva do que para aquelas
pessoas que sentiram medo então raiva
acaba sendo um combustível também de
recuperação também o combustível de
melhora quando você sofre algum tipo de
Julho quando você sofre alguma coisa E o
pior é que no dia a dia a gente
relaciona muito a raiva é um sentimento
feio um sentimento que a gente não
deveria sentir e a gente não tem a mesma
o mesmo preconceito por exemplo com medo
né quando um deles pode fazer muito
melhor por você se você sentir raiva ali
no momento que você sofrem Júlia você
pode recuperar com mais facilidade você
pode realmente voltar à normalidade
muito mais cedo do que se você sentisse
simplesmente medo se você se esconder né
é resposta do seu corpo que promove
força e que te dá energia para se
recuperar de uma situação ruim ou para
voltar à normalidade depois de passar
por um período de estresse ou de trauma
de alguma maneira
Oi e eu tenho uma história muito
particular com ódio da da forma como
ódio mudou a minha vida mesmo aí eu
tenho um transtorno chamado TDH é
transtorno de Déficit de Atenção e
hiperatividade é isso que faz com que eu
tenha falado essa sequência de palavras
absurdas aí num prazo muito curto de
tempo e você tem que prestar atenção e
se esforçar para poder entender o que
que eu tô falando nada a velocidade é
esse transtorno não produz só isso eu só
não falo rápido comigo movimento muito
mais no dia a dia do que uma pessoa
normal e além de tudo se passa um
mosquito aqui agora por exemplo a chance
de eu ficar olhando para o mosquito
Esqueceu que eu tô falando aqui ela
existe então o DH ele tem diversas
implicações e por isso quando você tem
teriaga normalmente você não é o que a
gente considera um bom aluno na escola
ainda que eu tirasse notas boas e que eu
fosse Criativo o que eu conseguisse
soluções para os problemas eu que me
Desce bem nas provas e eu me dei bem na
maioria das provas os professores não
ficar muito satisfeitos com o aluno que
se levanta na do meio e começa a
Caminhar pela sala vou começar a
conversar puxar papo com o outro acaba
tirando aquela normalidade da aula é que
a gente quer né que as crianças fiquem
sentadinhas em fileiras e fazendo o que
o professor está mandando então numa
dessas enquanto editava meu professor de
alguma maneira ele fica eu fazia a
sétima série ele já cansado
provavelmente não julgo de forma alguma
mas ele já cansaram provavelmente do ter
feito isso por muitas vezes a me falou
para ficar quieto e falou que eu não
seria ninguém na vida de eu continuar
agindo daquela maneira problema eu não
estava procurando ajuda aquela maneira
então não tinha nada que eu pudesse
fazer o que me pedisse de agir daquela
maneira Na época eu já tinha recebido o
diagnóstico de tdha mas minha mãe não
queria que eu procurasse o tratamento
específico utilizando o medicamento
então obviamente mesmo da eu ia
continuar daquele jeito assim como
continuei desse jeito por muitos anos
mas ele eu fiquei com muita raiva mesmo
porque a Eu não conseguiria fazer
diferente ainda que eu quisesse ele
tinha me mandado ficar quieto e ainda me
traz ou não é um destino onde eu não é a
vida passaram-se alguns anos na já com
18 para 19 anos eu era diretor de um
jornal esse mesmo professor ele entrou
pela porta da frente lá no jornal e
pediu para falar com o senhor Raul Sena
provavelmente não se lembrava do meu
nome e eu desci e fui atendê-lo na minha
secretária para o óleo tá até um pulando
te esperando lá embaixo desse vai
atender ou não eu quero falar com seu
pai entendeu Falei não meu pai não
trabalha aqui não se chama Raul Sena é
comigo mesmo que você quer falar ele
chama seu superior daí a secretaria
percebendo que a situação estava se
complicando hálito Olha você não vai
conseguir falar com ninguém acima dele é
isso mesmo esse é o diretor da empresa
que você tava esperando e daí eu vou
oferecer ajuda para ele normalmente mas
lembrei ele né para quem não ia ser nada
na vida até que não tá mal
E aí
bom então ha ha
e eu acabei percebendo que o ódio ele
não mudou só minha vida como ele tem
inúmeras Outras aplicações
para as pessoas de modo em geral no meu
canal hoje o alcance 300 mil pessoas eu
decidi que eu ia começar a fazer
exercícios físicos e eu quis explicar
para as pessoas como que eu ia conseguir
fazer exercícios físicos utilizando
necessariamente a força do Óleo a
comecei a ir à academia todos os dias e
dá o dedo do meio para academia porque
isso me motivava e até lá ficava com
muita raiva de fazer exercícios e eu
conseguia chegar até academia movido
pelo puro força pela pura força do ódio
e mostrar dedo comecei a fazer isso da
primeira vez fiz um desafio de quinze
dias depois um de 30 depois um de 90 e
com o tempo eu percebi que uma legião de
pessoas fazendo a mesma coisa mais de
1.500 pessoas que iam para academia
todos os dias da o dedo para os
exercícios físicos e conseguindo fazer
utilizar o ódio delas como combustível
para produzir as coisas E essas
afirmações provavelmente vão te chocar
né como que a gente pode utilizar um
sentimento que comumente é associado a
algo feio algo que a gente não deveria
agradar o manter dentro da gente mas é o
sentimento mais abundante do ser humano
se você parar para pensar não tem nada
que te aproxime né de uma pessoa que às
vezes está dentro de um presídio ou de
um psicopata que não tem os mesmos
sentimentos que a gente é certo o ódio
né o ódio é um sentimento que você
compartilha com todos os outros seres
leva as espécies todo mundo sente raiva
todo mundo sente ódio a gente pode
escolher muito bem É o que a gente vai
fazer com isso E aí para você não se
sentir mal de ter que escutar isso de
mim eu vou trazer alguém mais sensato
para te contar a mesma coisa né o autor
do livro Como transformar um autor na
que é o autor arun Gandhi que é neto do
pacifista Mahatma Gandhi ele cria um
livro fala na mesma coisa como
transformar a raiva em combustível para
mudar e para você provocar uma
transformação é realmente de dentro de
você e não externa né não tenha vergonha
então de sente ódio você pode escolher
exatamente o que você vai fazer com seu
áudio não é uma imposição que você tem
que agredir alguém que você tá com raiva
ou que você precisa necessariamente
fazer alguma coisa que você vai se
arrepender depois o áudio ele é um como
tipo abundante assim como a gasolina
você pode utilizar para colocar fogo no
palco e se você pode utilizar gasolina
para mover seu carro daqui até a cidade
mais próxima e lá você pode para o seu
trabalho pode ser um médico salvar vidas
então mesmo combustível a serve para ele
coisas o áudio da mesma forma você pode
utilizar para fazer mal para alguém ou
você pode utilizar o óleo realmente para
melhorar a sua vida e a o mundo como
tudo bem no dicionário o ódio que eu a
definição que ele é a versão intensa
motivada por medo raiva ou em Julho a
sofrida então o ódio ele é sempre
motivado quando você sofre algum tipo de
Julho e esse é o nome que a gente dá
para ódio sentimento que você tem quando
você passa por alguma situação de alguém
te fez mal de alguma maneira é ódio o
nome que você quiser para ele mas é esse
então da próxima vez que você levar uma
Fechada no trânsito Não desperdice seu
ódio não é xingando o motorista ele não
merece que você gaste isso combustível
com ele você pode esperar chegar no seu
escritório aproveitar aquele relatório
você tá devendo a 15 dias e movido pelo
puro extrato do ódio ali você pode
concluir da melhor maneira possível
então eu recomendo que vocês Se
perguntem toda vez que vocês sentirem
raiva ódio alguma maneira o que eu posso
fazer com meu ódio hoje e
eu tenho um recado especial para essa
frase que mudou minha vida
é muito obrigado
E aí